[Musik]
mit
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally bell
heute gibt's einen richtig leckeren und
vor allem sehr saftigen sonntags kommen
denn ich habe hier einen falschen kuchen
und zwar dieses mal mit einem rührteig
das heißt ohne hilfe zeigt und vor allem
mit schokolade
den hat noch keiner gemacht ich weiß
nicht welche traditionen der ich schon
wieder 14 statt einer ohne hefeteig und
auch früher zeigt mit schoko also haben
wir gedacht mach doch mal was neues oder
ipod touch auch richtig lecker in der
branche macht nichts ich ja schon ein
bisschen länger her ist glaube ich wird
da mal an die abgelegt oder machen eine
neue wenn auch nicht und updates ja auf
jeden fall
wer also ich bin zurzeit muss man
einfach zeitstrukturen man wie gut
wissen wollte ich auch vor allem weil
dieser weg sind und da macht man
leckeren kuchen drauf mit bittet also
mitten im schnee drauf richtig gut ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
mit den pfannkuchen braucht ein kilo
flash drive eine prise salz 50 von
zucker 125 um weiche butter raphael
extrakt 125,31 220 gramm mehl 30 von
kakaopulver und halben teelöffel
backpulver eine tonkabohne eine
unbehandelte zitrone 100 milliliter
lauwarme milch und 60 gramm gehobelte
mandeln bevor ich jetzt den eu-vertrag
macher muss sie natürlich zuerst einmal
die flaschen und steine und war nimmt er
dann das letzte was wir jetzt sehen und
dann kommt da kam raus dass stein und
dann wird dir einfach noch ist er tot
[Musik]
architektur einmal verlieren und dann
vettel und damit ich jetzt mit dem
urteil weiter machen kann
lieber morath übergebe ich dir diese
aufgabe entschlossen kommt du darfst du
dir kurz machen und nicht mal in der
zwischenzeit in rührteig übrigens nur im
schwere schmuckstück im sketch stört das
kann gut sein und im norden bei
autoklaven nationen wobei mir sage hier
pflaume zu der runde und wechseln die
lange und letzte abschnitt lag
jedenfalls mache ich jetzt ein rührteig
wird im rührteig gebe ich jetzt das
eiweiß in eine große schüssel eine prise
salz und schlagzeilen machte ekström
was die auseinander
wolf becke sein
jetzt muss hier der zucker lang mit dazu
und wird etwa eine minute mit gerührt
bin einfach nicht fertig jetzt kurz zur
seite da kann man übrigens über monats
kopf einfach den einschnitt machen auf
seinem kopf selbst alles in der schützen
jetzt nehme ich eine meiner schritte und
auch flexible element und gäbe es die
weiße butter mit rein hier dann auch den
zucker und aston extrakt und die
mischung darf dann für drei bis vier
minuten cremig verrührt werden
jetzt kommen die eier nacheinander
[Musik]
hier habe ich jetzt die trockenen zu
fahren also backpulver und nähe und ihr
frei bist hier auch noch die tonkabohne
mit rein und die tonkabohne sind nun
ganz ganz tolles gehört nach vanille
aber auch nachweisbar
also irgendwie kann man es nicht so ganz
mit linien aber schmeckt auf jeden fall
ist sehr lecker was aber auch gut dass
douglas ist auf jeden fall sind
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch der zitronenschale
abrieb mit rein was auch sehr gut passen
würde wäre orangenschale auf jeden fall
müsst ihr darauf achten dass die
zitrusfrüchte nicht behandelt sind jetzt
gebe ich die mail mischung die warme -
und den zitronensaft einfach im wechsel
mit dazu und lasst den teig nur noch
kurz berühren
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den eischnee
unterheben und das mache ich gerne mit
dem schneebesen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der teig in meine backform
und zwar habe ich die auf 26 zentimeter
durchmesser eingestellt und stabile
dreieck schon verteilt das auch sehr
guten den teig papst wäre zum beispiel
etwas rum oder ein bisschen wasser da
bekommt ihr einfach diese zwischen
bisschen aroma mit seinen plänen ordnung
ist einfach aus der mitte heraus an
das heißt für somit kleine blume in der
mitte und arbeite mich dann nach außen
kämen durch
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier noch die gehobelte
mandeln drüber und ich finde sich jetzt
schon richtig gut aus ich glaube ich nie
mit nicht kommt bleibt alle fenster
viele fragen warum auf der messe zum
beispiel ob ich die rezepte vor backe
und dann im video zeigt ob ich sie
direkt ausprobieren der natürlich auch
wieder so ein beispiel ich probier's
einfach direkt aus jetzt hat es
eigentlich rechtlich gramm mandeln aber
nur 30 passen drauf
also wird man spontan improvisiert war
und so kommt der kuchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 140 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
wird einfach später die schnäppchen zu
machen und dann bin ich schon gespannt
auf den stock gesetzt und kuchen
das habe ich auch noch nicht
[Musik]
der kunde nichts gebacken haben abkühlen
lassen und gerade eben noch einflüssen
schnee bestreut und jetzt bars morath
probieren
also ich finde ihn ohne tiefen schnee
auch schon schön mit diesem spiel auch
schön auch mal erkennt schon die
zwetschgen immer so schön aber trocken
sein kann und sich super hübsch alles
probiert die einen kuchen schon im
backofen zuschauerin von und sie haben
auf der messe in dortmund auch wieder
ausgeholfen und in der facebook-gruppe
leckereien vom fernverkehr
da am po sitze immer gleich nachdem ich
mein video hochgeladen hat schon das
fertige resultat also die ich echt super
schnell und viele denken dann immer ich
schicke die rezepte vorher aber das
mache ich gar nicht sondern sie hat
einfach einen großen er anruft
fortschritt zur weg und sie weiß die
sally benutzt oft butter und zucker und
mehl und dann macht ihr einfach vorbei
das rezept nach und dann geht es sofort
aber nicht oder
manche verstehen ihr geschäft nicht du
hast noch im garten oder auf dem acker
auch gespannt ob ich da macht auch ganz
schön und ich finde es echt immer super
also da könnt ihr gerne alle mal
nachschauen und auch mitmachen und wir
gucken dann immer wehrmacht zuerst nach
rechts
nico bereits rege reihe von fällen
sexuell und lukas egger
ich probiere jetzt bin ich gespannt und
passt die kombination schokolade
mandelson und tonkabohne tonkabohne
nicht zu vergessen weg uns nicht so süß
und da kommt auch darauf an was für
[Musik]
verlässlich und wenn ihr bisschen
frischer säure empfehlen die forscher
die frischeren zu geben das ist euer
licht das soll mich sind ganz reaktion
im café jetzt die ganze ja ich hab die
kaffeemaschine angemacht oder zu
vergessen die herausgelassen michael
perfekte ehefrau fallen egal wie egal
was soll falls ihr jetzt auch lust auf
diesen leckeren und saftigen kuchen
bekommen habt dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei auf trainings welt.de und
ich finde ich ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss und lädt könnt ihr mal schreiben
was für euch das absolute zwetschen
rezept ist also gerade aus
mit dem bild auf jeden fall auch ein
stück und einen kaffee und für dich okay
nächsten sonntag sei das paar bei 1 515
auf eine tat gemacht auch hoch
[Musik]